bonjour excellent merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin en direct sur
arte france
le mouvement ne semble pas s'essouffler
onze mille personnes la semaine passée
18000 la semaine précédente vous vous
attendez à quel type de mobilisation
importante je suppose cet après midi le
chiffre d'au moins dix mille
manifestants est encore évoqué rien pour
la capitale
oui tout à fait on attend énormément de
monde d'ailleurs ce qui est assez
étonnant parce qu on est quand même
fin juillet début août en plein mois
estival en général ce sont il n'y a pas
vraiment de manifestants la cvmq c'est
la mobilisation est toujours soutenu
effectivement nous nous hâtons non
énormément le monde et malheureusement
nous attendons quelques perturbations
que nous avons traîné quelques
perturbations vous craignez des
débordements des violences cet après
midi oui tout à fait les services
d'enseignement ont bien mieux le doigt
dessus il y aurait quelques ultras et
black blocs 5 serait malheureusement qui
investirait les les différents cortèges
comme il ya énormément de deux
manifestations prévues
il ya quatre cortèges de prévenus donc
forcément notre action se sera pas
découpler sur la capitale il faut aussi
penser en province a énormément de
rassemblement aussi seront prévus en
province ce qui mobilise énormément de
fonctionnaires de police dont claude je
disais trois mille policiers seront
déployés sur paris avec nos collègues
des braves mike et les collègues qui
interviennent en moto au plus près des
malheureusement des perturbateurs parce
que finalement nous ce que nous voulons
c'est que les manifestations se passe
dans le calme
nous notre but c'est la liberté de
manifester c'est absolument pas empêcher
les gens manifester malheureusement les
casseurs sont là pour empêcher la
démocratie de s'exprimer
donc nous serons là pour
neutraliser les perturbateurs grasset et
les black blocks notamment vous venez
d'en parler vous ne parlez du dispositif
policier quel sera-t-il exactement on a
évoqué le chiffre de et vous l'avez dit
également 3000 membres des forces de
long de l'ordre rien qu'à paris
mais au delà des du personnel quel sera
le dispositif exactement écoutez donc je
vous ai dire les brèves mike la
préfecture de police les compagnies de
républicaines de sécurité les gendarmes
mobiles seront sur place avec appuyé par
les cannois aux acquis ce qui seront qui
attire viendront bien évidemment
occuperez des contestataires violent un
jour répète nous ne sommes pas violents
les policiers malheureusement répondent
à des actes violents pour finalement
nous nous met en porte-à-faux
allez vous montrer des mauvaises images
et dire que si la faute du gouvernement
si ça dégénère absolument pas nous
pourtant certains manifestants disent
souvent les policiers font preuve de
deux ailes au départ ce sont eux qui
commençaient ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui disent ça écoutez moi ce que je vous
répondrais c'est que puis nous signale
immédiatement quand ils ont des gens qui
sont en train de s'habiller en black
blocs qui sont en train de former les
blocs dans les cortèges ne nous lie
signaler pour que nous explique tron ces
individus pour que puis finalement puis
qu'ils puissent manifester dans le calme
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas donc
nous sommes obligés d'intervenir
effectivement en amont pour éviter le
ces rassemblements l'individu violent
on sait très bien qu'ils se regroupent
extrêmement vite donc nous devons être
réellement réaction perpétuelle pour
éviter ces nombreux débordements
donc forcément l'action des policiers
n'est pas forcément comprise par ces
individus qui veulent manifester qui
sont malheureusement dire à fleur de
peau contre le pass and i terre et qui
pensent que sept gouvernements qui leur
oblige différents différentes jeu chose
donc nous on est là en réaction et nous
sommes là pour garantir le maintien de
l'année de la liberté de manifester un
et nous sommes absolument vous avez des
consignes particulières qui émane de la
préfecture de police de paris
oui la plus grande fermeté face aux
casseurs
il est intolérable qui est à chaque
manifestation des casseurs des policiers
pris à partie mais 3000 membres des
forces de l'ordre pourront lavier
environ dix mille manifestants qui sont
attendus ça fait donc un policier pour
trois militants c'est pas un peu
démesuré quand même
écoutez nous ce qu'on veut c'est que les
mauvaises images disparaissent et comme
je vous ai dit il ya quand même des
nombreux rassemblements qui sont prévues
plus des rassemblements sauvages on le
sait très bien
les individus qui vont tenter d'aller
sur des lieux symboliques de la capitale
donc ça effectivement dispersées
énormément les forces mobiles mais c'est
une technique pour nous et pour nous pas
de grande facilité la tâche mais nous
serons une feront face comme toujours
avec détermination et là avec la plus
grande des ontologies policière qui nous
anime
un mot également
sur sur ce mouvement 1
est ce qui peut prendre de l'ampleur à
la rentrée vous avez dit on est au mois
de juillet un mois estival d'habitude
n'y a pas beaucoup de manifestations en
cette période de l'année
est ce que vous craignez la possibilité
de manifestations plus importantes
encore à la rentrée et qui se succèdent
chaque week-end un peu comme ce fut le
cas pendant deux ans avec les gilet
jaune écouter ce que nous disent les
renseignements 1 par rapport à une
rentrée sociale très très chargé donc on
verra ce que va ce sera en échouant suit
les annonces gouvernementales et on sait
très bien qu'à une minorité qui refuse
en bloc que toutes les décisions
politiques
effectivement nous nous attendons à une
rentrée sociale extrêmement chargé mais
apparemment un été aussi très
mouvementée donc on espère que ça se
passera dans le calme encore une fois
les policiers à sont là pour garantir le
droit de manifester dans le calme
c'est notre but et as as très bien mais
malheureusement on sait très bien que il
ya toujours des débordements d'individus
et qui sont là uniquement sont les
professionnels de la casse et comment
vous allez intervenir face comme vous
dites à ces professionnels de la casse
puisque à la clé d'étranglement ne fait
plus partie des techniques
d'interpellation policière une annonce
faite haïr via courrier par le patron de
la police nationale frédéric veaux une
technique controversée qui a remplacé
par par trois autres techniques oui
effectivement on va avoir les dans le
détail exactement quelqu'un quelles sont
les techniques qu'un qui nous demandent
un son d amener au sol d'après ce que
j'ai compris
nous nous allons effectivement nous
adapter sur le sur le terrain forcément
nous avons d'autres techniques
d'intervention en général sur le
maintien de l'ordre le but c'est quand
même de maintenir à distance les
individus et ne pas aller au moins à 10
ans a aidé à lever des communes et à
distance avec des ailes bd non plus tôt
avec du gaz lacrymogène le but c'est
vraiment maintenir à distance avec le
gaz lacrymogènes et je rappelle qu'il
faut pas ramasser les engins
un pyrotechnique qui utilisent qu'on
utilise pour lancer des grenades
lacrymogènes donc il faut absolument pas
y toucher
ça évitera les blessures qu'on peut voir
sur certains sur certains manifestants
les a faits d'effectivement sont
utilisées en général quand la la
graduation montain quand nous faisons
face à des individus particulièrement
déterminés ils veulent finalement se
payer du policier
merci accélérant de c'est la fin de
cette interview merci de nous avons
répondu je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat la police
en avant